une porte à la fois et xavier barsalou
duval temps de se faire réélire à
varennes d'ampli à boucher les patriotes
verchères par les gens sont pas là on
laisse un petit rat ce qu'on voit qu'on
est passé comme ça vaut au moins ils
savent qu'on est venu aura bonjour c'est
la ddiss député sortant du bloc
québécois le seul en banlieue sud de
montréal
je sais pas ce que tu penses du bloc en
général mais
oui j'ai voté pour vous c'est le fameux
merci nous sommes présents atteindre à
présent pour le québec dans les belles
années du parti la rive sud était
pourtant un château fort bloquiste comme
bien des régions du québec
mais d'un bleu sans équivoque la région
est devenue orange en 2011 puis rouge
orange en 2015 bonjour stéphane bergeron
la circonscription de montarville par
exemple est passée des mains
souverainiste oignons démocrate puis aux
libéraux vétéran de la politique
l'ex-ministre stéphane bergeron tente un
retour ils ont essayé autre chose que le
bloc 2 es2 demanda puis il ya beaucoup
de gens qui sont pas nécessairement très
très satisfait mais pour espérer avoir
du poids à ottawa
[Applaudissements]
il faut d'abord faire élire le chef dbk
elle fait de la saisie mais l'équipe dit
françois blanchet dans beloeil chambly
est convaincu d'un regain pour le parti
les gestes sont heureux en fait monsieur
blanchet le chef du bloc se présente
parce que la première fois de leur
histoire qu'un chef se présentent dans
le comté à tous les niveaux mais ici il
faut déloger le néo-démocrate matthew
dubé déjà deux mandats d'expérience
c'est déjà intéressant c'est un
puis bin chef du bloc c'est intéressant
aussi
et autre défi pour le parti faire
connaître son chef françois blanchet ce
que vous savez c'est qu'ils n'ont je
connais pas ce monsieur
non non françois blanchet non non pas du
tout oui mais à son kiosque la boum
accordé votre confiance
jamais jamais vous n'aurez alors
regretté il françois blanchet a réussi
en quelques mois l'impensable réunifier
son parti mais il reste à voir si ce
parti lui sera rallier suffisamment
d'électeurs pour retrouver un peu de son
lustre d'antan
ici julie marceau radio-canada beloeil